(rap music)
- What?
- [Other Tyler] Today's rough.
- Babin here is
all bent out of shape.
He just said today is rough.
To be very frank
with you Vayner Nation,
I don't give a fuck...
(rap music)
("Prologue" by Final State)
Period.
We're not going to be
able to use any of this.
Yesterday was fucking epic
because I was able to do a ton
of Instagram stories and
Snapchat stories for you guys
'cause I was traveling
in and out to Kansas City.
Not so much today.
Grinder in the
office but should be good.
Hope you have a great day.
Hello, my friend.
Good to see you.
Great to see you again.
Give me two seconds.
Facebook's the one
place that you can break out.
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- Because you can speak
English more than good enough.
- [Man] Okay.
- More than good enough.
- You just do the same thing.
- [Man] Okay.
- It's the same game,
it's one day at a time.
It's one day at a time.
It's making a video in English
to your Facebook fan page,--
- [Man] Yeah, yeah.
- and saying tag one, I think
you should make your community,
how many fans on Facebook?
- [Man] Right now I have
my personal profile is full,
obviously.
- Yeah, but the fan page.
- [Man] 20,000 in
Slovenian, Croatian.
- Which is a ton.
- [Man] But I have
English, 4-5,000.
We didn't start heavily.
- I got it.
Don't worry, there's
accounts where I have nothing.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Never worried
where you have small basis.
What I would say is...
On the Instagram
and the American,
on the Croatian, Slovenian
kind of speaking Facebook pages,
I would make English content.
- [Man] Okay, I have a lot.
- Original content
and make them part of it.
- [Man] Okay.
- If I told you
one piece of advice,
tonight in your
hotel room you say,
"My friends, today I want to
start the process of breaking
"into the American market."
- [Man] Okay.
- "And you can do me a huge
favor which is please tag one or
"two American or
English speaking friends."
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- And that will
start the process.
- [Man] Okay.
- And then the next day you
make a piece of content that's
motivational or
instructional or strategic.
- [Man] Okay.
- It's the place
of virality, man.
Here's who's crucial,
I'll tell you. You ready?
I'll tell you,
I'll tell you in two seconds.
A writer.
- [Man] Okay.
- Somebody who writes.
- [Man] Yeah.
- A video person like DRock.
And that may be
two people or one people.
DRock, and my people,
Tyler, they can film and edit.
Some people can only do one but
there's enough young kids who
can do both so
I would have one person.
I would try to
make it one person.
- [Man] Okay.
- Three, a designer.
Pictures, a designer.
Somebody who makes
pictures and quotes and images.
The next one is audio.
You need an audio technician.
So that you can do podcasts.
It's going to be very important.
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- So that's four.
And now number five,
up here, at the top.
- [Man] Yes, at the top.
- PM. Project manager.
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- Or architect.
We'll talk more, I'll help you.
- [Man] Okay, thank you.
- Alright, brother?
- [Man] Thank you.
- Real pleasure.
- [Man] Can we take a picture?
- Yeah, of course.
("2020 Vision" by JMKM)
Busy day.
How are you?
- [Man 2] How are you doin'?
- Really well, how are you?
- [Man 2] Good.
Okay, cool.
- Alright, brother,
have a great day.
- [Man 2] You too.
- Guys.
- [Jon] (laughs) I should
never have said that.
- I'm the best.
Listen, I'm sorry.
By the way, you
know why I say it?
I take no credit.
What the fuck did I do?
- [Nate] I don't know
what's going on right now.
- What's going on is
we're establishing that I'm the
greatest and that it's dangerous
for us to make ideas based off
of me because
I'm so fucking good.
- [Nate] Right. That's what I--
- That I take no credit for.
I give all the credit
to Tamara and Sasha.
When I say I'm the best,
mother fuckers who are watching
this vlog, when I say I'm the best
that's a compliment
to my mom and dad.
I didn't do shit.
First of all, it's so much
better to make decisions in your
life for yourself than
have other people do it.
I'm going nowhere,
I'm here for you forever.
Not gonna lose your number.
Like, I'm not mad.
You shouldn't be
leaving on these issues and
I can't let that happen.
Nobody will believe or
care about you more
than me at a power position.
It's impossible.
("2020 Vision" by JMKM)
- Such a pleasure to meet you.
- Thank you, man.
- You're a huge
inspiration to me.
- Thank you, bro.
- I just graduated college.
I founded about 15
different companies and
I'm selling my first one.
- I love it man, congrats.
- Next month.
- What's your name?
- My name is Michael Morrisel.
I think you'll be hopefully
seeing a lot of me around.
- I hope so, man.
- You know I had to
ask because you're here,
I know you're busy.
I don't want get in-between but
15 minutes for coffee at some
point or even just an email
to give you a couple of--
- Done deal. Send me an email to
Gary@Vaynermedia say you're the
dude that came in
with the, in the title,
with the skateboard.
- Okay.
- I'll remember
we'll figure something out.
- Perfect. Such a pleasure, man.
- Thanks for saying hello.
- [Other Tyler] Today's rough.
- [Gary] What?
- [Gary] Babin here
is all bent out of shape.
He just said today is rough.
To be very frank
with you Vayner Nation,
I don't give a fuck if Tyler or
you think today was rough
because I had 17 meetings that
he couldn't be a part of because
I'm actually running
a fucking business here.
I'm not from some fucking
teenage beanie bopper trying to
do a vlog or some fuckin'
influencer doing a fucking blog
or some fucking family that's
hoping for some free detergent
'cause of their fucking blog.
I'm fucking working
here Tyler so sorry that
your fucking
video blog is rough.
But let me tell
you what's not rough.
What's not rough is we're living
through the great era of ground
shift in marketing and business.
Everybody in this fucking
amazing town of New York City
which is, let me just tell
you everybody who's not here,
fucking vibrant at 10 P.M.
right now 'cause 98% of your
cities are fucking sleeping.
Everybody here is shitting their
collective fucking pants because
the ground is shifting.
Everything that our grandparents
and parents grew up with,
everything that we knew,
tried and true,
the stable pillars
of media, commerce,
influence, persuasion,
the way we make decisions,
the things we buy and how,
what is cool and what is not
is on fucking call.
The world is on call.
And you know what
that means, hustlers,
the opportunity is obnoxious.
So whether you're focusing on
vlogs or influencers or how to
hack Instagram stories or how
to create Alexa Voice Skills,
or how to create your own
podcast 'cause you see
I'm fucking full committed.
If you are not
following my podcast,
I'm fucking pissed.
The way I call today, the sum
up of all my meetings today,
none of which you just watched
is that the earth is moving.
There's instability in the
foundation of how it was which
makes an innovator like
me really fucking happy.
And what
suffocates all you B-players
'cause you like it
nice, slow and stable.
Let it be very clear
with this ending rant,
that game is over.
And the people that are gonna
win over the next five to seven
years are gonna be very
comfortable in controlled
fucking chaos so you
better get your speed up.
You better work harder.
You better work smarter.
You better try things.
You better keep your
subjectiveness and your ego at
the door 'cause that slows you
down and it doesn't make you do.
You better fucking move.
("2020 Vision" by JMKM)